instead of playing night before white
could have just played the move a 5-4
for black and this is a movie very is
very happy to make because the pawn
system significantly worse on a5 than a
seven why would that be let's put this
on the board two main reasons alright so
welcome everybody I'm here to give the
lecture tonight as a guest lecture on
the secret life of bonds I understand
this is a normal weekly session but
hopefully I can be a guest and provide
some kind of decent commentary so for
those who don't know me my name is Sam
Franklin's
I'm from California but I am pretty
frequent visitor to st. Louis where
among other events that like to play
includes the u.s. Championship which was
won by some Joker this year that didn't
deserve to win but you know everyone
gets lucky now and then but what I've
done recently as well is I've written a
book called small steps a giant
improvement master pawn playing chess
it's all about pawns and whatnot so I
thought while I was in st. Louis it
might be great to talk a bit about pawns
and the secret life pawns as we're
speaking about so what we see here in
this position in front of us looks
nothing like pawns it's sort of a
typical rookie game White is one pawn up
but black structure is very solid and
everyone who's played rook end games in
their life knows that they have tendency
to end in draws White's extra pawn is on
the Queen side where blacks king is
sitting pretty comfortably and if white
were to just in the style of a true
caveman say you know what my extra pawns
on the Queen side let's just start
trading stuff until I make a passed pawn
he's probably not gonna win the game
this pawn on c4 is very well controlled
it's to be very hard to get the black
King out of the way there's still
chances in it's not like the players are
just going to agree a draw here but
clearly something is not it's missing
it's like the extra pawn is not working
well enough so what I specifically wrote
about in my book is the concept that
pawns do not move backwards this is a
very basic rule of chess that I'm sure
everyone here knows but it's simple
principles can go a long way and I broke
down a lot of the key reasons that pawns
would want to move backwards in my book
now those five reasons in order are one
the pawn becomes vulnerable it's just
simply too far advanced in the
opponent's camp we rounded up in cow
shirt or potentially could be harassed
too would be that the pawn advancing has
loosened your control over key squares
or blocked key line or something like
that or open to key line that your
opponent can use three would be it
blocks your pieces four would be that it
compromises your King safety and five
would be that it makes a hook now in
this position I think we can all agree
that neither King is going to feel too
much danger we can probably discount the
part about sking safety nobody has any
pawns that are so far advanced that you
worry about them getting captured
so what really we're gonna be talking
about here is the weaknesses of squares
so at this point why that's to figure
out how to proceed in the endgame we've
already seen that the cavemen of
approach of just trying to set you're
passed pawn in motion mobilize your 300
to 302 majority doesn't seem to yield
the proper benefits that we'd like so at
this point I'd like to invite everyone
to take a little bit of time and think
to themselves what should white play in
this position and how should you best
try to Greece's advantage so the hint
can we play a 5 yes you can and I
believe that's the second-best move you
are happy to have played a 5 you don't
want these pawns looking at each other
just the general principle to keep in
mind simple principles go a long way is
when you're ahead in material you want
to trade pieces when you're behind you
want to trade pawns as such white would
like to avoid pawn trades and I move
like a 5 potentially fixes the a6 pawn
is a weakness this definitely is a good
idea it is in my opinion the second best
move but I think what has something more
pressing that you'd like to get done
first okay and what are the what is the
objective of such moves do you think
black will agree to a rook trade no so
you can certainly play them move like f3
or king e4 is this our King D 3 as this
gentleman is suggested to try to prepare
for rookie 4 and we'll see that this
theme does come up later in this endgame
but for the moment it doesn't seem to
accomplish very much let's say you go
king d3 and I don't know black just
waste to move in plays rook e 7 and
after rook e4 black gives a check you
didn't trade rooks it doesn't feel like
you've accomplished too much just yet I
think there's a much more important move
first yes okay so rook F 4 has been
suggested can you explain to me the
purpose of this move
right so rook f4 is a dual-purpose move
first of all you're threatened to simply
grab the pawn on f7 your one pawn up
which may or may not be enough to when
if you take a second pawn you're very
likely to win again so black has to do
something about the threat to this pawn
on f7 now rook f4 is the best when it
was played in the game black played f5
which I believe is the most resilient
response but let's suppose he were to
play rook e7 instead how should I
proceed now yes Rick f6 check and now
we're seeing that black the pawn and a6
is weak and this is another key point
when I'm saying you don't want to be
trading pawns when your head material if
the moves h ax b v + HX b5 had been
included and in this position black did
not have the hanging pawn in a 6 because
it had already been exchanged black
maybe you could consider advancing the
king instead of retreating as such now
after king - the king is forced back to
b7 and now after a 5 blacks position is
completely hopeless he's stuck his rook
is stuck on the seventh rank his King
has stuck defending a6 so in addition to
white being upon a black is absolutely
paralyzed and whites most basic winning
plan is to just run the King straight to
d6 where it will harass this rook and
then he can start playing B 3 and C 4
once the King is active black is
completely lost and there's no
discussion to be had so but that
represents very poor defense on black
sport and the best move is of course
instead of rookie seven to play f5 now
this as the key point of it saves the
pawn that you have just attacked while
also preventing you from playing riff f6
but remember the point of this is that
pawns do not move backwards as it turns
out I believe it's very much in White's
favor to have provoked black's pawn to
f5 why do you guys think that might be
so I say it again
well the problem if you played g4 is
that remember what we were saying is
we're trying to avoid the exchange
response now a whole bunch of pawns are
being exchanged yeah I suppose you could
do this but now there's so many pawns
being chopped off that I would think
after something like rook f8 black is
starting to get very good holding
chances it's going to be very annoying
to hang on to this pawn if you start
playing something like this and I give
check and then I give check again if I
simplify to three on two on one side
it's definitely a draw okay and then I
give you this check and then I come back
to f4 I think that I don't know I mean
maybe you still have some winning
chances because you can play a five here
but it's quite clear that you're not
happy that so many pawns are being
exchanged so this wasn't the reason g4
is not the right idea but it is
important that we've provoked upon to f5
yes there in the back yes at some point
we are going to try to attack g6 by
playing f5 black is not only weakened
this pawn on g6 which it will become a
long-term weakness
he's also weakened a lot of the key
squares like f4 and g5 that potentially
your king could go to harass so let's
see how the game proceeded to some
extent what white did not play g4 so I
have to look at my other compete here so
after f5 white played h4 natural enough
to fix these pawns as they as they stand
and after rook e6 this gentlemen's move
here was played a 5 to keep the pawns
from being exchanged and black still has
nothing to do is his pieces are about as
active as they can get so he plays rook
e5 now what should what do yes
sorry rook you want cook f3 and rook III
and then after rook d5 then what king c2
yes you're on the right track but you
just you need to expand upon your idea
yes right why it's planned to win the
game now is to bring his King straight
to g5 where he will harass the g6 pawn
now it seems like there's a problem that
the white king is cut off along the
e-file that the black rook is
controlling so nicely but now we see one
of the points of white's extra pawn
while it's not actually in any danger of
becoming a queen right now it does mean
that black absolutely cannot allow a
king and pawn and given that rook f3 may
have been faster than what was done I
don't really mind what was played wipe
the braudys rook back to d4 and after
rook e8 he played rook to e3 why had all
the time in the world maybe this was a
wasted move maybe it wasn't doesn't
really matter
and then after rook d3 black is in a
really bad spot because what's going to
happen is what's gonna play rook e3 he
can also play before at some point if he
wants to what's in the game black played
rook b8 which in my view is just
capitulation but let's say black were to
just sit with something like this and
now if you want you can play b4 just to
make sure there's no weaknesses
whatsoever but I don't think it's
necessary let's start with rook III
because we have an extra pawn black is
unable to trade these rooks this King
and pawn endgame is routinely winning
for a white because now the extra pass
pawn will matter but so let's say black
is more adamant and wants to avoid an
exchange of rooks now after King's at
you - first of all rookie six check is a
big threat that black has to take care
of let's say he plays rook d6 and now we
see this if blacks Palmer back on f7 as
it was in the start of this exercise
black could play moves like rook f6
check to force the King back he could
play move like f6 to keep the white king
from invading the Kings side as is
specifically because white is provoked
this pawn to f5 he has a very clear plan
of bringing the King in to take this
week g6 pawn once the King reaches g5 he
should win very easily by swinging the
rook into the back rank so it's black
seeing that this was going to happen
that there wasn't really anything he
could do to stop it
he tried rook b8 now I don't really want
to create a
sighs I'm too much because I believe his
position was lost no matter what he did
and with rook b8 you could at least see
he has a plan to potentially play before
and make counter play but it's pretty
hard to believe and why could again play
b4 if he so desired but I'd take no
issue with what he did which was King
III and after b4 King f4 BC three white
took with the rook and after a king d5
King g5 rook takes B to f4 for one key
moment white actually has even given
back his pawn and in an endgame where
originally white was a pawn up now we
see nominally equal material on the
board but of course that doesn't matter
in the slightest because white has
gotten four it was a clear plan of the
position with his king who is now about
to ransack blacks King side and there
wasn't much more resistance to be had
so following rookie to king g6 and rook
a5 it's very clear whose pawns are more
dangerous and after King takes h5 just
to point out King takes f5 is not to be
recommended anyone want to point out why
yes sir
yeah you can never trust these kids in
the end games but if they see a tactic
to win the rook they will always find it
so no that's absolutely correct and this
would be a great way to lose the winning
game but after a king takes to h5 what
should win very routinely the game
continued King g4 rook b3 rook b5 rook
a3 a5 king g5 and it's very clear that
the white h-bond is significantly faster
than the black a pawn and uh well the
game just lasted a few more moves King
e4 h5 rook b8 h6 rook GA check King f6
and black I decided he'd seen enough at
this point so I thought this was a very
nice example of a case where we saw a
pawn that clearly wanted to move
backwards now the first several chapters
of my book are about trying to keep your
own pawns from moving too far forward to
create weaknesses in your position and
while it's certainly good to avoid
hurting yourself in that regard you
definitely in order to ultimately win a
chess game sometimes points fall into
your lap sometimes opponents make
mistakes unprovoked this can happen but
if we go back to how this
actually ended up with his pawn on f5
which turned out to be a huge weakness
when white skin came in can we blame
black for playing the move out 5 when he
did absolutely not
I'm sure black probably understood that
maybe he understood at the time that f5
was a strategic detriment maybe he just
made the movement hit the clock because
he had to and there was no other choice
and bothered to think about it but
clearly white just afford him no choice
in the matter and the second section of
my book is about situations like this
where you're specifically trying to
provoke opponents pawns forward in a way
that becomes a problem for their
position now here we're specifically
talking about I would say the second
reason the first reason being that the
pawn could become vulnerable here you
might argue that the g6 pawn becomes
formal world by all this but the g6 poun
was not the pawn that was moving it was
the f5 pond at the f7 pond that was
moving and when we provoked this f7 pawn
forward it lost control over the key
squares g5 in g6 g5 fill up the white
King in and then g6 to take the pawn and
provoking your opponent's pawns forward
to weaken key squares is a very
important theme that we'll see all
throughout chess and every phase of the
game opening middle game an endgame now
this this public position was featured
in my book but it's a little known fact
that since my book came out I've had a
pretty good run I won the US
Championship I won the cap block of
Memorial I raised my rating some my my
peak high now I like to think that most
of this is because I've been working
hard and that work is finally starting
to pay off but it's possible that
writing my book had something to do with
it and I've definitely noticed in my own
play that I'm noticing these themes
consciously a little bit more than I was
before I wrote the book so what I'd like
to do now is show a couple games that
I've played recently that came that I
played after this book came out but
where I became more consciously aware of
the kind of pawn weaknesses we're
talking about and specifically the
concept of trying to provoke your
opponent's palms forward so we can
accuse square so the database here isn't
updated enough so I have to just copy
this position in my hand but that's ok
also if anybody wants to look up this
game later the game was federal check
against spirits from Poland Ukraine
match 2012 so let me just show a game
that I played here
and not save that this one was my game
against a wonder Liang from the last
round of the US Championship that
clinched me the gold medal so the
beginning phase of the game was
certainly interesting and I think worthy
of study but a little bit outside the
scope of what I'm hoping to discuss but
I'd like to I guess probably it's faster
to just play the moves than to set up
the position because it's fewer clicks
so we're just gonna go through a 40 60
45 chop-chop knight c6 don't get me the
little spinning beach ball of doom
Knight f6 Bishop f4 Bishop c4 Queen b3
and I wonder play d5 but luckily I was
ready with h3 you should have played
Knight a5 here so it takes takes check
again I'm skipping through this because
it's not relevant to what I was hoping
to discuss g6 tricky one Queen c7 g5
Chevy 296 Bishop b5 so I want to start
here now at this point I wonder played
Bishop g7 this may well be the best move
but I was certainly because I'm planning
on potentially taking on c6 and jumping
into e5 with a knight which would cause
problems but as soon as he played Bishop
g7 even if it's best I'm gonna be a
pretty happy guy because it's gonna be a
very sad piece so here white is clearly
better he has a better structure his
pieces are more active the bishop on g7
and the knight on e6 do not inspire
confidence and white stroke on h1 it's
more active than the rook on h8 that
said well it's clear white as the better
end of this position it's not so clear
what he's going to do increases
advantage further blacks position is
very solid and there's no real
weaknesses just yet I mean we could
argue about d5 being a weakness but it's
protected for now and it's very hard to
see what's going to increase the
pressure on it with any of his other
pieces but I forget who said it first
but there's a very true part of chess
which is that one bad piece makes a bad
position so what is whites bad piece
here yes
yeah the 92 is not very good it can't
come to be three or f3 it's dominated by
the d5 pawn White's position apart from
this not n d2 is sort of picture-perfect
everything else makes really good sense
but the knight on g2 needs to improve
and it's not so easy to see how but then
I want to come up with a plan for how
this night can be improved yeah
and what doesn't I do on edge too okay
so kingi one night f 1 night h2 on a
scale from snail to cheetah where is
this slap where does this lie probably
closer to the snail right yeah this
doesn't this is very slow and black is
not without counter play I think if he
has an option he would like to play h6
pretty soon to potentially open the H
file so but it's an interesting idea
what we want to do is and clearly the
Knight doesn't have so many great
options and you're right that moving a
piece to clear a square is a pretty good
idea but boy the white knight has a
better route to join the game yes okay
so if you're trying to bring the knight
to h2 the night is the night h2 would be
faster but again I don't really think it
accomplishes that much and in the
meantime the g5 pawn is hanging and one
the g5 pawn falls a lot of whites barn
will go white plus is a pawn down so
this isn't best either let's fly this
like bughouse let's take this Knight
imagine this nice just off the board
and we can drop it somewhere where do we
want to put it this is a good way to try
to figure out how to improve the knight
d3 yes d3 is I think is an excellent
square for the knight it's potentially
looking at E 5 and C 5 which are both
weeks potentially hack her ass on the F
for pawn none of these squares right now
look that great because they're under
control but Y can potentially provoke
weaknesses and then the nut and d3 will
be excellent so what's the best way for
the right to get to d3 yes Queen a4 is
the best move this also carries the
incidental threaded Bishop takes c6
which would severely compromised black's
pawn structure so if black were to try
to proceed along with his own play with
something like h6 and what's say we chop
everything and then go Bishop takes c6
and black has to take with the pawn
because otherwise Queen a7 comes a
position like this one looks awful for
black his King is going to come under
serious fire you might play b4 just to
fix this pawn as hard as you can and
then Knight b3 comes in Knight c5 or
Knight a5 and the black Kings gonna get
taken for a ride this is not going to be
fun for black so when I for comes with
the tempo the Queen wasn't doing that
much on b3
black really does not want to allow
white to force this pawn structure even
if he was able to do so in a way that
forced the Queen's off something like
this I think is just an absolutely
miserable endgame for black because
white will play Knight b3 and these
pawns on AC and a6 and c6 will prove to
be long-term weaknesses and white has
plans to play stuff like Knight b3 and
say Knight c5 to remove them at any six
and rook h4 comes and the pawn on f4
will likely be lost
this looks pretty hopeless so I wonder
found the best move with rook d6 and his
point is that if Bishop c6 he's able to
keep his pawn structure intact because
now Queen f7 would fail to ruck ice X
this is a bad way to lose the u.s.
championship but here I was able to
execute my idea with night b3 I think
the computer preferred before but from a
human point of view this is just
nonsense because it allows black to
actually I have a plan to play against
the c3 weakness and I think Knight b3
makes a lot more sense so another thing
is when you put pressure on people they
start to voluntarily worse than their
own position and here my plan during the
game was next to move to play Knight c1
but where else could the knight mb3 look
to go night c5 is a serious idea as well
now I don't know if a wonder had played
King b8 or something I don't know if I
would have played Knight c1 or Knight c5
I didn't have to make that decision but
if white is able to bring his knight to
c5 you can potentially get rid of this e
6 night which is keeping the e-file
closed keeping the f4 pawn protected and
that could be a real problem for black
again it wasn't my idea but it's
something that black has to keep in mind
I was expecting a 6 and following Bishop
c6 rook c6 the best move is Knight c5
but my plan was not c1 in any case by
provoking things like this a wonder
played b6 and this I fir this I believe
blacks position is beyond saving
why is b6 such a bad move
exactly he's weak in the white squares
now in this case but I did not force him
to play b6 but I sort of encouraged it
I definitely provoked it even if it
wasn't completely forced I mean I think
after a six-block is worse but the game
goes on and here I think it was largely
because I put a wonder under pressure
and I made moves that sort of enticed
him to play the weakening move b6 that
he did it I don't think a wander didn't
understand this as a weakening move I
think he just sort of felt he didn't
have that much choice in the matter
and as a result I was able to provoke my
opponent's pawn forward in a way that
severely compromised his position moving
forward I now execute my plan to bring
my Knights of d3 he went Knight B 893
and king b7
okay what is blacks plan yeah so black
wants to play a six in addition to that
seeming like it will trap the bishop and
win material on the spot there's just
the general rule of thumb you don't want
your you want your pasta in the same
color as your opponent's Bishop in
obstacle or de Bishop positions because
right now my bishop on d5 is the boss of
the board all right black spine is a six
what should white do yeah mate before is
a very strong move now I am preventing
black from playing a6 the night seems
pretty active it could potentially
threaten the d5 pawn as well let's say
black plays a5 this night this just has
to go right back where it came from did
we just lose time all right well you
just made two moves back-to-back Knight
b3 tonight 93 to b4 and now us so black
had a bad position let's repeat the
position why don't black play a 5 to a 7
this is the whole point pawns do not
move backwards why it's basically just
burden to Tempe on night before to d3
but essentially if you look at this
position a second ago if black had
played a5 which maybe he had to do
instead of playing Knight before white
could have just played the move a5 for
for black and this is a movie very is
very happy to make because the pawn
system significantly worse on a5 than a
7 why would that be let's put this on
the board two main reasons why is the
pawn worse on a5 than i7
yes that's correct
Kings position is easier to be opened
before this is the concept of making a
hook this is the concept of making a
hook before now becomes a very
legitimate idea for white to open up
blacks King previously if we go back
several moves and we saw where we picked
up the position we're like yeah what's
better but it's hard to find a plan to
increase his advantage and it's hard to
to see how to break through when we move
forward and we see what I did to provoke
the the black pawn to be six of three on
ip3 and then yeah once you've seen the
pawn provoke to be six
we've weakened some squares and to some
extent that was a wander playing it
voluntarily it was a mistake after all
but then here I mean if a five was the
best move which it may well have been
although I do think it's lost by playing
Knight before I sort of force black to
play a5 he didn't have a choice in the
matter
and after 93 I've made a hook in his
position on a5 I can now play b4 to open
up his King in a position where I
previously was struggling to find a plan
in addition this bishop on b5 which
thoroughly dominates the net mb8 is now
stuck on b5 for the rest of the game as
black no longer has the a7 to a6 advance
to boot the bishop off of its perch make
sense to everybody so I think this is
what black had to do now I wonder played
quindi 8 which I mean I again I think
his position was more or less lost so I
don't want to criticize him too much but
this definitely hastened the defeat
because I had to calculate a line here
and now I just want to show it because
all the calculation and tactics in this
game are certainly interesting and
important to go over it is outside the
scope of what I want to talk about which
is just the promise of pawns not moving
backwards and sort of the secret life of
pawns so to speak the best move now is
95 and it's a hard move to see because
you'd really don't want to let black
trade this stupid Bishop on g7 for a
knight because that Bishop was such a
bad piece you're also hanging the e5
pawn the g5 pawn if you start
calculating you realize that blacks
position just falls apart that 95 makes
twin threats of Knights of 7 and Knight
c6 so black can play Knight takes d5 and
avoid one such threat but after knight
c6 black is facing mass
problems after some like takes takes
Queen i6 Queen i7 rookie 7 and whom 88
are all massive threats this just
completely falls apart on the spot
that's not too hard to figure out but if
Bishop takes e5 this looks like Black is
achieving a great deal strategically by
trading off such a bad Bishop
but unfortunately for him we're seeing
the tactics this rook is trapped now I
had to calculate a little bit because he
can play Knight c5 to attack my queen
and try to clear up the e6 square for
his rook but the variations are pretty
straightforward and very nice still does
any want to try to find the win for
white here
let's think of it first this is forcing
chess checks and captures always have to
consider those first from looking at
forcing combinations okay so he takes d6
has been called this sacrifices the
Queen after Knight takes a for else be
keeping travná T really keeping track of
material excuse me right so at the
moment but what white is down a queen
for a rock but now rookie 7 check comes
in blacks in a quandary if he takes the
rook net material is equal but both a4
is hanging any a queen is coming blacks
clearly going to lose this so let's say
he tries to save the King what if he
plays King c8 right Rick c7 this would
be track mate if not this now materials
equal again and once again two hanging
pieces so white will be a piece up in
the endgame and finally if King to a8
which is probably the most resilient but
white definitely still wins
yeah 96 is the best move and here
rook takes a seven is checkmate and very
serious threat issues that problem if
Bishop c6 I believe this also wins but
after knight c6 Knight c6 blacks gonna
have to go up the Queen for the rook and
at this point at least the pawn doesn't
become a queen like right away because
we don't have a LightSquared Bishop
anymore it still should be winning is I
don't think rook takes h7 can be stopped
but you might end up in something like
this I don't know 98 97 it should win
but it's a little bit more work it's
better to start with knight c6 when rook
a7 maid is a massive threat if Queen e7
de 7 and the e pawn will win and if
Knight takes c6 Bishop c6 check and it
just checks all the way through p7 check
if King a8 rook b6 is mate and if king
c8 d 7 comes so so this variation is
nice not wildly difficult but still even
in the most positional of games you want
to be calculating some lines anyhow with
both Knight f7 and knight c6 being
massive threats the wonder felt that
needs to play Queen c7 and then after
Queen b3 the game is basically over
because Knight takes d5 is coming and
once the d5 pawn Falls there's really
not much to fight for
he tried rook d8 but now keep in mind
that the d8 square is occupied again so
after the rook takes h7 which the rook
had to leave of 1 upon again Knight g5
impossible because the bishop hangs and
again bit should be 5 impossible because
after D the rook is again trapped
because the J square is occupied I
wonder how does one opportunity to play
a 6 Bishop d3 and if black could play a
5 here which he would he really wants to
take this not any 5 the problem is if he
takes it now after rook takes e5 the d5
pawn will fall as well what he'd really
like to do is play a 5 kicked my knight
away and now take this guy and here he's
still in big trouble but he's sort of
fighting back after something like this
he's not falling apart right away the g5
pawn is going to potentially fall but
unfortunately for him I was ready he
didn't play a5 but if he did yeah and I
takes d5 and after
rook takes d5 Bishop before it's just
complete collapse the rook on d5 is lost
enough Queen f6 Knight f7 and everything
Thanks
so this was routinely winning so for one
critical move black was not able to play
a5 he got his King off of this diagonal
first but once again white has another
very nice move here to provoke one of
blacks pawns forward to weaken his
position
what should white play
probably black is ready to play a5 next
so you want to be ready for that
yeah quina for back the queen has served
her purpose on b3 she attacked the d5
pawn brought blacks rook to d8 which in
turn allowed the h1 rook to snap on h7
now the threat of taking on a6 is
completely crushing so black must play
a5 and what square has he weakened
what should we do sorry but after night
c2 a black will take on e5 and here is
sort of fighting back you should be lost
but the whole goal was to not let black
take on e5 what should we do with this
weakens what when you played a5 what
score did you weaken no spawning was the
pawn in a 6 1 and a 6 what score was it
controlling it doesn't control anymore
how can we use this go to art yeah
the bishop comes right back because the
Queen's on a for this Knight cannot be
taken account of the pin the bishop
comes right back to the best where it
was on again Bishop e5 is prevented
because of de and though because the
bishop is back on b5 as opposed to on d3
the rook is once again trapped and then
after a king b7 the knight comes back to
d3 we saw a similar position not too
long ago where white didn't Eve where we
were saying black should have played a 5
way back when in this position after a
593 blacks position is really bad and it
seems basically lost because before it's
coming he has no counter play and all
the squares are weak if we go forward to
the way the game actually went black was
facing all of the same problems except
if you look sorry 1895 King a southern
Queen f4 a5 Bishop e5 King b7
incidentally here wide like Bishop e8
was collapsed but I just didn't care I
was looking for the simplest moves after
93 we have all the same problems except
in addition to that black is now a clean
pawn down and my one semi passive piece
on h1 has entered the game on h7 the
rest of this game I don't think is too
important to go over for our purposes
although I was a little bit more
stressed out than normal playing it
because I knew I was completely wedding
but I also knew 50 grand was potentially
in the pocket with a win and that's fair
amount of money to be stressed out over
anyhow like to move on to another game
that I played recently
I think this was a good example of
showing how provoking the black pawns
forward on the queenside seriously
compromised this position and let me
take down the US Championship so the
next game I want to look at is the game
I put in my most recent event which was
a private match with Peters fiddler and
now well I actually lost a match I won
the first game and in fine style which
left me pretty optimistic and then but
then he struck back with a beautiful
game in Game two so we were even at 1-1
where I thought we both played really
well in the first two games me and game
won him in Game two
then in games three four and five I
really let it slip I lost Game four from
like a fine position games three and
five I missed some chances ultimately I
lost a match but it was a good learning
experience but I want to go over the
first game the one I won not
specifically because I want it but
because it really had a lot to do with
the concept of pawns not moving
backwards well the games I lost or more
to do with the concept of my King
getting slaughtered which was not much
fun but you know props to Peter for
playing well let me hold up this
position so I had played a pretty good
game for the most part but I had
somewhat let it slip so I get this
position here rook on d3 pawn B three
and a four rook on C to rock on e6 so we
see another rook endgame
here so I put a quite good game for the
most part but I was definitely winning
at some point here I've made my life a
bit difficult I'm still one pawn up in
this rook endgame but my pieces are a
bit passive and I actually think if
Peter had found the right move here he
would have drawn and we'll come back to
that at the end because we'll see what
happens but he played rook b2 which I
think was I think this move should lose
the game I'm not a hundred percent
confidence because there's other
defensive resources but well let's
discuss this position a little bit why
it's opponent but why is he not winning
early it's not clearly laying yes yeah
it's not passed pawns yet but there's a
much bigger reason yeah the four rooks
but specifically how about activity yes
sir
hard to make a passed pawn yeah but I
don't think what wants to make a
possible he wants to win pawns yes the
real problem I would say is that White's
pieces are passive so for example okay
and the game he played rook to be to but
black could play them of like rookie to
I have to play rook g3 now and White's
pieces are horribly passive black must
now retreat since the b6 pawn is hanging
but we see a position like this one come
and whites King and his g3 Rooker really
not very inspiring and as a result it's
hard to see how he's going to make
progress so after a rugby - I played I
think a very strong move h4 and the
point of this first of all I want to
advance h5 to get more space but the
real thing is I really want the h3
square to be clear for my King and we'll
see why in a second so rook B to h4 so
Spitler found nothing better than rookie
to e2 and I mean I could try rook takes
p6 but something like this I think if I
want to avoid a draw I have to stop
touching the rook at some point and well
clearly blacks getting his own past
pawns and this was much more
double-edged if I had to do that to get
any winning chances I would have
seriously considered it but I thought I
had found a better plan so rook g3 and
again black has to bring the rook back
to e6 but we need a plan for white to
win the game I started with h5 which I
think is best but okay now he and mark
time with rook b6 let's let's talk in a
little more detail here let's see if
anyone can come up with the plan for
white to win the game any thoughts
move the king up so King edge through
the problem is kh3 rook d1 threatens
mate and I think you have to just come
right back sorry King back to extreme
well it you'll repeat the position after
a king edge - you'll have you'll have to
play King back to its - and then black
will have to play rook back to d6 so no
harm done you made a mistake
repeat the position find a better move
it's always nice when you can do that
sometimes sometimes if you make a
mistake you have to you don't have the
option to repeat the position but okay
here we need a plan to win the game
we've clearly seen making a passed pawn
with something like b4 will never work
among other things rook d4 we'll just
take it
so what's why can I actually do it seems
like Black has all of his weaknesses
under control
yes you need to open black King you
would white playing g5 but this goes
back to what we were saying earlier we
don't want to trade so many pawns what
you want to do is find another weakness
in blacks position this rook here is
serving no defensive roles whatsoever
it's serving an active role that's gonna
be difficult but what do you but the
rook the rook getting from b5 to b7 is
going to be tough but you're on the
right track
what does that rook what are you trying
to do with your rook on visa right you
want to attack the f7 pawn the problem
with rook f3 is black will play rook to
e2 work to do - excuse me what's the
point of rookie 5 where do you want to
go maybe I like rook before more what
wants to bring his rook to f4 and then
bring his other rook to f3
when this happens black will have a very
difficult decision of what to do about
the f7 pawn
right that creates a serious problem for
black he doesn't even need rook f6 let's
suppose black we're taking his typical
strategy of just waiting and then black
plays here if rook but then maybe rook
takes b3 this may still be winning after
rook b3 and rook b6 but I'm not sure but
I think the real thing is here now
blacks rook is stuck in the passive role
not yours
now your King is free he's not playing
rook to to anymore you're able to start
making progress now whether this is
enough to win the game I don't know I
mean we'll find out but clearly why it's
starting to make progress he's got his
king free he's got his rooks free at
some point I can play a move like rook
back to before I let's say black keeps
waiting what if I play rook back to
before now if you play rookie see what
if I run with my King I give you g2 and
I take it take b6 this looks like a very
serious chance for white my king is not
in any danger anymore and it's gonna
take you forever to die get your pawns
going this seems like a decent try
anyhow after rugby for Smith they're
quite clearly understood what my plan
wasn't he played g5 but I was extremely
happy to see this move because I have
provoked his pawn forward to weaken an
important square what does white do rook
right back to b5 so a second ago we're
like well I'll play rook before and then
I'll play rook b5 back but again black
cannot play g5 back to g6 now white
still has the same plan at his disposal
to play first rook F 5 and then rook f3
to harass this pawn so after g5 here
black played f6 now I think this was
impatient he definitely could have at
least waited for me to put rooks on the
F file to play f6 but he played it here
now the position has changed
dramatically because the black King has
been opened what should white play yes
okay rook c3 let's say black plays rook
to do - who's King is in more danger do
we have to come back to g3 as the pawn
on f6 caused a problem for black King
where let's say I fade and now right and
as it turns out yeah okay we won the
pawn we were always winning the pawn
when black doubled his rooks on the
second rank but instead of just winning
the pot now blacks Kings also in the
Smasher and following rook takes G to
check black is one time PO to slow I'll
play King h1 you can check me forever
but eventually my king will run to see
one where the rook controls this square
you can give me all the checks you want
you can doesn't matter which rook you
choose this one that one ultimately my
King comes back here no more checks rook
b8 mate is coming and as soon as black
has to make a passive move like this one
white will easily win with response
blacks King is clearly in more danger
than whites and white will win so so
this seems like it's winning but only
because I was able to encourage black to
play f6 by trying to bring my Brooks DF
file now instead here's fiddler found a
pretty clever move I think with rook to
e2 and his point with this is I don't if
I play something like rook c7 check King
f8 I don't have an immediate way to get
this rook to b8 I can play something
like a5 but this is one critical tempo
slower and now after rook t2 we see the
point of rookie 2 from b2 is these rooks
are closer and here my King doesn't get
to the C file because the black rook on
do 2 is in the way and this is a
perpetual just 2750 guys they're tough
let's think this I'm not sure this will
work here checking me for my thang
yeah maybe this works too let me think
hey 552 rookie sex check King edge 3
okay maybe this is wedding but it's not
so easy for example let's say we follow
this line and then let's go
maybe this rooks with check and then you
come King e4 and then I play rook f4
check and I'll give you this check and
then let's say I'm ready with rook C to
check rook takes okay this should win I
don't know there was some reason I
dislike this I'm trying to remember it
but maybe this was also winning but I
liked what I did even more so rook c3
rookie - now that I've provoked f6 I
thought I just needed to bring pieces in
and what I came up with was my rook
coming to b5 was to play rook to a5 to
try to get f6 through now once that
happened I just brought my rook back to
before my point is now simple this work
is coming to this works coming to c4 and
then coming into the position black
played rook d2 and after a rook g3 back
we've had this whole crazy dance this
entire time but what I've done is
provoked the pawns to g5 and f6 and as a
result now moves like rook before to c7
or accomplishing something when they
weren't before so instead of this
shredder triad king f7 and I played rook
c4 King e6 and now he's managed to get
his kick out of the Smasher but now he's
abandoned his H pawn so after rook to c8
which threatens rookie a check among
others the game promptly ended so I
brought the rook back to g3 and here's
Midler realized I'm coming for his h6
fun so he tried to come back but after
rook h8 there's nothing to be done if he
plays King g7 white plays rook b8 and I
think it was you who mentioned a long
time ago you wanted to put the rook on
b7 on the other side it took a long time
but white eventually got to where you
wanted
now here blacks in a tough spot because
his b6 pawn is hanging if he tries to
save it he frees the g3 rook and after
rook b7 check and rook c3 black does not
have time to come back to do too because
if maid and white finally wins instead
Svidler played rook f2
pointing out that if Rick takes h6 King
g7 and now my rook will get trapped
and it's not like it's getting taken but
both of my rooks are completely stuck
and I don't see how I break through but
one more accurate move finished the game
and want to find it
yes rook h7 and now blacks in a tough
spot because he has to either lettuce
can get cut off on the back rank with
something like King g8 one after rook b7
he's facing baiting threats again or if
he wants to avoid that he can play King
e6 but now I can safely take the pawn in
h6 because he cannot kill my rook so I
was very happy with this game and this
was really the bright spot of what was
otherwise a frustrating and tough match
for me he was a very tough opponent and
he won a very nice match but the first
game i really liked and i specifically
liked how i was able to put the
principles of my book into action of
working hard to provoke your opponent's
pawns forward in a way that they want to
enjoy in this case provoking black into
playing g6 to g5 and then provoking and
supplying f7 to f 6 critically weak in
the seventh rank which is what I used to
get enough play to win the game when it
looked like my pieces were kind of stuck
I think we're going to end that for now
but thanks everyone for coming this
month
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]